[Musica]
ciao a tutti benvenuti solidaristico
sono in italia e oggi trova cela mezzo
diamo fare lo slime con la ruota e il
calendario dell'oggetto massi in ogni in
e di casella del calendario dell'avvento
ci sono degli ingredienti per fare lo
slime avete visto il nostro video in cui
avremo tutti i calendari dell'avvento di
tiger sapete che ci siamo rimasti molto
male per questo calendario è un altro se
non lo avete questa potrà vederlo poi
dopo questo video così vedrete la nostra
reazione con cui grazie mille per i
consigli su come riempirlo
avevo deciso di utilizzare questo
appunto mettendoci tanti ingredienti che
la carta ha già fatto cadere qualcosa
agli ingredienti slime alcuni un po più
sfigati
molto belli i sunyer la ruota deciderà a
quali cappelle dovremmo aprire con
ingredienti dovremmo aggiungere al
nostro slime dovremmo aprire due caselle
per volte infatti vedete che ci sono due
numeri in ogni casella masi e sono
attivi in giallo e vediamo servita
ladybird il tir era in verde o no no
tiro non fa niente se mai preso vedere
altri
cioè l'ancestrale non la ruota abbiamo
ancora un altro calendario della mente
un nuoto consigliateci miei commenti
come utilizzarlo in un'altra sala
denuncia come facciamo l'altro il
cioccolato e caramelle consigliateci
colti challenge divertente nei commenti
in cui utilizzare quel calendario
dell'ambiente vuote ora dei prati prende
tempo car mettetevi comodi
iniziamo carta pormi di test carta
fornito il numero 8 e 20
vediamo se sono già spiegata allora qua
c'è il numero 8 del 20 anche per la
carta capo a 8 abbiamo clay giallo c'è
lo attirato perché io sono team giallo
si fanno sapere chi sarà soprattutto non
è online con la con la trasparente
frizza hanno quindi vuol dire che io
tirerò inverno che farete bene che cosa
c'era questo piace almeno piacciono
ci sono delle conigliette arancioni
luminose sono bello allora per questo
sono contenta per questo un po di meno
prima di aggiungere limba pescarne anche
vitale poi aggiungiamo assieme numero 1
e numero crediti facebook con questa che
pur bellissima 43 dice bob balaban
allora inizia il numero uno non mi
preoccupava già aperto perché se avete
visto pinne sapete il perché si forma
questi sembra verde ma io lo farò
diventare celestino morta chi perde un
ufficio per questo motivo diventerà un
centro maree del prezzo vito
diventerebbero grappolo 13 e vediamo
il numero 13 al forno della cucina
camere tutte le frattempo numero 13
anziana a forma di babbo natale
[Musica]
sono le famiglie nel flash tesi davvero
attivate diverse cioè io praticamente
ottima posizione si giallo arancione
giallo e ben clorata allora iniziamo con
la chiesa lasciano il lirico visitare
una con la trappolette la metto a
pezzetti v come fa vitale tra questi
camminare la impegnate a serbo non sa
neanche come rischiarlo nintendo pichler
via porta mondovì rischiarlo
c'è qualche cosina nostrani verso esseri
umani glitter certo strano in questo
club però è carino dai almeno il giallo
e non bird e vediamo invece allora io
cominci vediamo un po io comincia subito
col colore dai colorante verde
non so come non ho avuto la maledizione
finora se n'è visto anche un sacco di
armi
no adesso vedrai che diventerà più
chiaro diventerà un verde acqua minerale
io non solo perde qualcosa bene che
mandiamo verde rai vedrai che adesso
diventerà smeraldo
[Risate]
dai veramente le sue preferite tra
l'altro vitale olio diametro ball perché
mi sono sempre poi dall'online motivetti
le ferite e come alcuni vertici siano
capitate due cose e sono sicuro che mi
cadranno tutte fa l'amore soprano
trasparenti adesso magari su un bel
fishbowl super so perché riesce un altro
colorata da coloro di blu che si fa così
slime del nostro team privati a toccare
a me 4 12 e 24 tra l'altro in questi
muri ci sono i minori profitti perché il
2 il mio numero preferito quindi se due
volte quindi spero che sarà forte un
altra metodi ma dai motiva le palline
blu j24 maioli nuovo che fortuna il 24 è
praticamente l'ultimo giorno quello che
è il regalo più creando quindi che cosa
ci trova schiuma da barba a mille
all'ora
la decorazione più grande di tutti
è opportuno allora le palline sorte che
adora perché sono con un coltello e poi
la relazione c'è potremmo ingredienti 20
prontostico sono stata fortunata perché
il 2 mi ha portato fortuna che non mi è
ancora capitato
persistendo
mi permetto di oggi in giro
[Musica]
allora un'attrice già capitato come gira
il piano va bene ci troviamo
[Musica]
10 20 10 22
vediamo dieci giorni secco a bloccare
non mi piacciono non lo voglio che belli
charlie perbellini davvero uno dei
diamanti diamantini schiacciati colorate
quando allora aggiungiamo in archivio le
famiglie blu che mi sono capitate questo
slam fra undici colori perché non farò
sfigata all'ultimo di colorante giallo
[Musica]
po difficile da mischiare con il clima
forse una volta che lo attiviamo con le
mani e riusciamo mischiarlo ad allearvi
o forse cosa ho paura che il blu delle
palline rilasci colore e quindi
gialloblù diventi verde oppure maggiore
elezioni così diventò anche la facciamo
un po troppo tanto ti cadranno tutte
dopo non è vero è vero sì è vero
vediamo un po beh non è male
e un bel giallo con un mix di numeri in
farlo serve noi vediamo proprio per le
moto già allora iniziò perverte ieri
subito con prestiti a mancini tutto
questo in poi presso un bellissimo come
stanno non piacere di vedere o rivedere
fare vedere i diamanti colorati fuori e
poi ci mettiamo vediamo poi aggiunge che
lo sta migliorando
quando sai che quando lo faccio io lo
slide che moneta questo lo facciamo
nulla magari piace di più finora questo
dai gambe bravo io sì l'ho chiamato le
11 al 23 11 e 23 quindi 11 a questo
pubblica capito già in effetti
applicando e rompendo tutto compiamo
tutti i criteri di tipo stelline corsini
avete inviato poi firmato poi abbiamo
che però marco mainardi amore se perde
pure lo stand dopo quando sarà attivo
che un panettone prestiti il panettone a
thimphu pandoro tutto è invitare tutti e
due
poi mangia tutti io preferisco il
pandoro perché non vi piacciono i
canditi
i pulp anche se non sembrano proprio dei
canditi tra l'altro i cardini verso il
panettone
piano piano il 4 del 16
l'accesso di neri e lato mi escono sto
vitale un ingrediente un ingrediente che
farà guidare coperte mangiamo bertolino
un altro il 16 vediamo come aperto
questa cartella subentrata è pupazzo di
neve si è sciolta dai medici non c'è
niente colorate 1 marzo arancione puliti
arancione verde diventa che siamo sempre
detti qui sono dimenticati di simi
andati già iscrivervi nazionale di vita
le vicine anche se non fosse tentato di
video un sacco di gameplay anche quindi
vi lascio il leaking descritte in questo
video andate stile rischiava il canale
tv tale facile da ricorsi li scrive
lasciate un commento ok inizia con
questi mi avete regalato voi e firma
cotti che sono su forcellini
io mischiarli c'è questa sua musica tipo
1 slime carnevale da quante cose
colorate ha dentro lo slam carnevale a
natale si ma non so dire quale sarà
dedicata legambiente e poi purtroppo a
me con le colleghe allegato un po certo
che ho fatto
facciamolo di mandato non si scompongono
rovina una zuppa di carote
ma veniamo allora il primo piano parte
prima che vieterà oro giallo oro e
mettiamo giallo e poi il secondo
ingredienti piacerà nel verde diventerà
maroniane brutto diventa non lo facciamo
diventare scuro scuro o grigio grigio
lo facciamo diventare scuro scuro così
poi diventa nero e diventerà ora quando
guardate questa volta resi veramente ha
fatto diventa cancale questo è
bellissimo qualche veicolo galaxy come
armi che chiaro
vediamo cos'altro ti capita ho messo
troppo giallo vabbè non importa dal
bellissimo l allora delle case del che
hanno due perché i dubbi porta fruttano
quindi sia di quel 2 12 quindi 214 14 e
qui all'albero di natale che i due è
molto pi capitale mentre dicevi che il
giallo non ti piace vada quindi adesso
che colore nero va c'è che colore
diventerà il giallo con linee romagnole
tra gritto 14 salvamento 14 con le sue
scelte
vedo con tanto di feriti forse torino
nel male
glitter rosa rosanero effettivamente ci
sta bene bravo
papà
[Musica]
86 18 chimica tra ci sta bene che cos'è
questo bene ancora le giovanili ma
questi ricadranno di un ulteriore
italiano di anche in questo caso dopo
quanto sia vitale come non far cadere
queste decorazioni si fornisce sempre
cercano di mettere dobbiamo ammettere il
colorante nell immediato non diventi la
perizia
magari un colorante lo si odia bello è
un po strano diventando color marrone
che sembra picazio giallo e nero o no no
deve dare ai gridi ti prego
mettiamo il grinta è diventato senati
simo adesso serve da glitter rosa
bellissimo proprio questo matera che
tutto diventa alberghi palude il mio è
bello ora gli altri a che colore è
brutta ma questo è il colore come col
richiamo un berbero pericolo corrieri
palleggiano bellissimo ha un colore è il
proprio particolare
salvando però è che bello siamo quasi
alla fia 5 17 7 allora 5 su una
decorazione verde questo poteva capitare
adesso gli occhietti d'amore che capita
batterà perfetto
secondo me si porta fortuna
meno male sono dei glitter viola scuro
pro questi occhi dai gira posso credere
che ha tirato così buio nominativi che
fortuna cerro allora è rimasto il 97 io
scelgo il 19 perché c'è l'asinello no al
19 però scelto vediamo sull'asinello di
porta fortuna ai sa cos'è
ritornerò era una sorta di mero a me
piace un sacco questo colore tipo bitter
bronzo 7 giu
ma l'arbitrato che cos'è perché altre
altri ghetti e tre feriti
allora abbiamo delle stelline bernucci
cose non so se si vedono viola e
vogliamo quindi ancora non è uscito
hotel possibile taglio chi purtroppo che
rovineranno line che diventa un mostro
perché gli occhi e kakà con un bel
colore ma è che è rimasto giallo almeno
il mio al marrone come la tua
vediamo chi vince questa volta poi
glitter viola per fortuna quindi un bel
colore bella musica e colore mi sa che
meglio il mio del tuo è certo ora che
bello di sempre un otello mischiata con
la senape mafioso dai vediamo il tuo
bellissimo il colore di questi clip
magari ma salgono magari bronzo a chi è
stato più fortunato questo tour pressi
di calcolare rimane tutto è ma nemmeno
apriamo questa parte pure quelli che
sapevano due mister questo diritto e
rovescio di vitale o dai quantità di
verde e lo sto colorando oppure di
mettere i glitter lo sto colorando solo
quel kit bellissimo quanta vuota quante
sfumature
questa la nuova galassia è una nuova
classe la galassia aperta si sono le
nostre sono due è rimasto in nove e il
39 c'è il fiocchetto interessa da un
foglietto linus siccome io adoro gli
animali che puoi scegliere ultimi due
piedi se scegli where do io poi brando
l'altra si ok quindi tre qui a torino 15
cos'era il 15 non lo vedo e colpi abolì
sino sappiamo bene di occhetto il
tavolino
non credo
si no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
lo spettacolo che hanno scelto pure ad
ora hai scelto tu quindi non è stata di
perdere al potere sei tu riesci a inter
verde
oddio allora il betouch e il colorante
verde che non è ancora capitato a
nessuno tanto in tanto
quindi ho capita a me adesso volte dopo
tanta tanta di glitter e grandi
argentati col nome del sacchetto non è
vero niente
[Musica]
quindi c'è il 2
l'ultimissima cardella che capitata nel
verde secondo me uscirà in media
fantastico scommettiamo che uscirà il
galaxy che andiamo a mettere nel mio mix
supermeet maledettissimi clipper 20 cioè
io pensavo di averla scampata fino
all'ultimo è però però meno male è
uscito su 10 tenuta niente magari ti
aiuta migliorarlo con contaminato e
niente e poi questi glitter bellissimi
perché sono più spessi anche questi mi
avete regalato accendono tipo sale pepe
si batte i pochi che tra pochi non
bellissimi vita che casino un'europa
troppo idropinico l'inter mi posso
attivare il vostro proprio curiosa di
vedere di che colore diventa allora puoi
color anni magari me lo fa salvare un
pochettino e poi mettiamo il verde che
l'altro l'ultima casella che mi è
capitato
vediamo un po abbiamo anche coloro
uscirà fuori
te l'ho detto come uscivo un calcio
bellissimo certe ma guarda che bello né
importanza è una violazione dello stato
così fortunato che ci sono capitate solo
come ingredienti coloranti e glitter
iniziale siamo capitati tutto negli
ingredienti possibili e immaginabili
ora vediamo una volta attivi quale il
fluire io ero e sono diventate dello
stesso colore del nostro team di
sceneggiature barry coincidenza
allora ora andiamo ad attivarmi e poi
potrete dare il voto sia per aspettano
che persone smr siete pronti ora due
ragazzi ecco il mio slime lo so il
colore è piuttosto strano proprio color
mostarda e ve lo dico già non mi piace
perché non so se sia il clay o che cosa
ma non è elastico vedete in futuro o più
quasi un occhio che spunta di cui
comunque non mi piace il colore perché
proprio mostarda e poi appunto non è
molto elastico c'è un pò si allunga però
è un po duro non sono mancate il cofa
ridispone mr qualcuno filippo indù penso
che sia impossibile
[Musica]
penso che il clay l'abbia ridotto molto
male
poi è uscito una trocchia vabbè comunque
no non mi piace per niente
fatemi sapere voi cosa ne pensate di
questo slime vediamo ora quello di
wow wow qua troppo grazie ad attività
per dissi ma questa è la galassia
galassia verde sì ho chiamato così
questo dai classi aperte bello chiamo io
già sto giro per me tagliate napolitano
bolle non sono tantissimi ma per ora ci
sono ma cosa di cui sono estremamente
soddisfatto e che lo attivato poco
talmente poco infatti che non riusciva a
stare in piedi ma almeno non cadono
tutte
mi piace è verde morbido fortissimo e su
un core divertente che bello allora
rilascio qui il sondaggio per votare se
ho vinto io ti ho vinto vitale anche se
abbastanza più chi ha vinto questa e vi
lasciamo ora fa quattro cartellini su
cui cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video ripreso una riconta caselline per
vedere per tre altri video è per vedere
il canale di evitare di manama